twitter やめようかな読めるなぁ
グンちゃん肇社長ですて投げて今日おいそがしいそがしで東京にいるわけなんです
けれども皆さんを押され楽しんでますね私もそんなオシャレと言われるよう何体分右で
はなくこのなんかなぁ気分でこねくり付けてリピーターが2人してくれる制度なんです
けども
世の中にはお皿に関心がない人もいるんですよそんなんだが抑えに興味なさのとミック
さん今からお家で招き入れまして
オサレな人間ならばちょっと
落ちた人のアクセサリー等の変化にもすぐ気づくと思うんですよなので私はネックレス
人としてるんですけども今日は今日はなんとですね
デックリセが増えていったらいつ気付くのかやってみたいと思いますだけで b 方
参加めちゃくちゃヤバイ量のネックですかいましたても何十万円分がイノテック使った
んですよ
うわぁ凄い
以後に言ってるネックレスね号車を買いました
いろんな州なるんですけども合計だけ見ると400こと100個で500個ですねまぁ
1個1000円くらいするんで山一帯も10万円分ぐらいかな
この日客をためだけど a 1使ってるよ
考え
でしょうかん
[音楽]
クリックの
文章不正なん atf がはピアノや
器ですねん
僕ないようなんですよ
んです
写したりで準備をして遊べてくださいになりなりライン
阿蘇ゴロン族を治るもんって書かれていった
花のがちょうどいいわけません
てしまったので早速
いきましょうね
でしょます
ん
思う un amico 目2つ付けてるのおかしいと思うんで
これを当たり前だと思わせていきましょうなのでこれで突っ込まれてもノーカウント
これがゼロからスタートです
ますかジョジョ
[音楽]
サシャさせますちゃこのさあ村がはしませんちょっとポップには見てないですね
チェックやしてみましょうキープしているとさあまずは目にも遭いんだよね
ニックン
ここです件バレが来てしますけどもありますね
あ責め30秒かかってるんですよ
アンユンはっはったん
あけずのっ
いるぞ
お金が出ていく今
もうちょい載せ後あるんです
もう水の元素が決まった
me
[音楽]
今後も夏行くよ
これは去っ7目立つでしょ
だってこれよクリアばたらよなぁこれも大きいな
ハッチすっ
ん
んああこれはバレるでしょつは今撮りました
10ハイツ
自衛
20円だったん
前に早いのはなりません
もちあるクリックビーチも
9匹も
うん
猫のないもん
よく打ちもも
風のなんか何かあるんです
マッハスマートおよそん
rar
ん
配送車バカまじめまたばれてないクリがキモかっただけなんですねっクリスタッカー
ついてるか入ってないんだまだバレてない2210個増やす20個で行ってみましょう
112です14151610年の重圧
受給20
まだいけそうですねすぎています
ません
オススメでしょうか
自分やってないんやってないですーラース
やりましょういえば招福動きません9位流れを感じます
と思っん
をしましたん
9月も
うん現在いいやりますともだよ
になりましょう
[音楽]
乾パン痴女がありますから
ブーブー50個で行ってみようと思います22340ニッキー2012
おっ
あっはぁっ
まずバレないと思いました行ってきます
[音楽]
すべてがソースのミラー
もがて釣っ
練馬区もう鉄製ですかん早瀬でしょね
いいやらせるぞ yeah
あーだよさあ
ana
だよ0ああ
re うおれっ
動画まあねありがたいと素晴らしいましょうう
こんなところに座らせなん
こんなのものですもう雪の種類だけ
ね任天堂ショックだった
は無いんだっはい
すっごいヒットはいっ
朝バレてないとこれまだいけますねちょっとバイの100個でやってみましょう
[音楽]
いやーもうまあなんかずっ牛俺
撮影後同市おいています
ございますかん
9オーバーさせ
2年生
あれでください遊びませんね
た体の準備ですよね
さあやばい100個付きでもあいつまだ気付いてませんん
バッと言えどもこれまだいきそうだなて300個で行ってみようと思います
えっ
うっ
ん
[音楽]
ってやっぱすねー
とっ
たとえ同じ
[音楽]
思いやった
13年かかっていず
希望
凄い凄いねこれくらいすごい自分な素晴らしい
ブースからやりなんとかなすごい
気づいて言ってるもやばいってそれん
水ゼロストップなんだよ
重い
デザインでそれ
サイロ強と思う
まだ気付いただけじゃないんだから
休まず増税はてるようじゃないっ
300個付けたんですけど多分まだ気付いじゃないです親父みたいな感じはあったと
思うけれども
俺のネックレスが続いていることには気づいてなかったです最後もうちょっとベースで
500個で引っ張れるかバレないか見ていこうと思います
[音楽]
2ああ
そうしましたーーーん
b モーションよし
[音楽]
ん
が気づいたことはありませんか
今初めて気づきましたーーー
実は
ニックレスが
だんだん増えていくドッキリでした
た
実は
あなたが気付かないうちに
あなたやクズか大事に僕のネックレスがだんだん増えてってたんですね
気づきませんでしたかいつ買うか
はっはっはっ時大成功デー
これきもってそういったぷてぃあんまんこ
つーかなでもあれ気づいてなかったです俺の首がキモイと思っただけだぜ
ねえねえプレゼンに大祭決定なかったんでガーバー関さあ
まだまだ押されに向かうんですねもっとさせバーキン3月たりとかさーんんじゃあ一
えっ
僕もお洒落になるぞ頑張ってくださいだろこれ
[音楽]
うぉっは